so we'll get started I'm going to be
talking about something called
polynomial chaos the word chaos is
interesting it's not about chaos theory
as we describe it now
chaos used in the early 20th century was
often used by mathematicians to describe
stochastic processes so that's what
we're going to be talking about if you
wanted to follow along with this talk
there at the URL up there you can
download the ipython notebook and run it
alongside more than free to do that but
I'll be going through and this is
basically an introduction to this topic
called polynomial chaos it's not very
common in most data science fields but
it's used a lot in certain engineering
disciplines and the reason the
motivation behind polynomial chaos is
that it allows us to quantify
uncertainty in parametric systems which
is something that we might do as a data
scientist if we have a model and we want
to understand how randomness effects
that model so just a few notes about
what I'm going to be talking about this
talk is tagged at expert level I will be
talking about some advanced mathematics
you don't need to understand it to
appreciate what's going on but I'm not
going to have time to go through a set
up and explain all of these concepts so
just to give like judge the audience
like where where your comfort level is
how many people here have heard of the
radon nikodem derivative okay it's fine
if you don't know what that is but
that's the basis of the math that is
that I'm going to be talking about I'm
not going to be doing cute not going to
be doing Q&A at after this talk if you'd
like clarification on the slide please
feel free to interrupt me or please feel
free to talk to me in the hallway
afterwards I prefer it one on one rather
than trying to address what is the
equivalent of to graduate level
functional analysis courses in a quick
question and a final warning I am a
c-sharp developer by training I write
Python a bit like a functional
programmer I'm not sure where that came
from
I tried to minimize that a little bit so
I'm not going to be doing a lot of
MapReduce but I will be doing some
currying stuff like that and the code
that I write and I have like one really
horrible line of code that I'm going to
apologize to you for right now so as I
mentioned polynomial chaos is a way to
represent random variables or random
processes in terms of orthogonal
polynomials and this is maybe a little
bit of a foreign concept but we're all
probably familiar with pca principal
component analysis to some degree
principal component analysis basically
what we do is we take a an operator
which in this case is the covariance
matrix we diagonalize it through through
a process over a finite dimensional
vector space and what PCA really is is
it's a special case of what's known as
the Kosambi Carkoon and loez transform
which is sometimes called a spectral
expansion of a random variable and all
that that is is it's writing a random
variable in terms of an eigenfunction
basis and in pca we choose the
eigenvectors of this symmetric matrix to
be our eigenfunction basis polynomial
chaos is the same thing except we're
choosing orthogonal polynomial families
so polynomial chaos is really the
simplest way to think about it would be
like PCA over an infinite dimensional
polynomial vector space instead of a
vector space of reals so visually we
look at this and I promise this won't be
all math I'm going to get to Python but
I do have to do a little bit of setup
the KL transform looks like this
PCA what we're really doing when we
invoke sy pi is just this series on the
bottom here and you don't have to
understand the notation or worry about
what it is it's really just to look at
what the form is polynomial chaos is
very much the same thing where we take a
random variable X or a random process X
and we decompose it in terms of
determining deterministic coefficients X
sub I over orthogonal polynomial basis C
sub I and that orthogonal polynomial is
going to be written in terms of a random
variable that we
choose and that's the most important
that's the core thing of what polynomial
chaos is why would we want to do this
well in practice when we look at the
distributions that we see in our data
whatever it is that we're analyzing it
could be customer data add data network
traffic data these distributions very
rarely look like the canonical
distributions of real life or in in
theory rather like you never really see
something that's truly Gaussian you
never really see something that's truly
uniform a lot of times you look at data
and it's like get this bimodal and
you're like oh well what am I supposed
to do with that so this technique allows
us to do a few things we could use it to
accelerate Monte Carlo simulation we can
use it to handle distributions that are
really messy in terms of distributions
that we can control so we don't need to
try to figure out what the distribution
of our data is in our database in order
to do modeling on it we can just say
well I'm going to represent it in terms
of a polynomial chaos expansion no that
didn't really render very well but
basically what it is is the mathematics
behind it some very interesting math
that came out in the mid 20th century
the theorem by Cameron and Martin
basically one of the consequences of it
is that this representation this that
infinite series that I displayed is
going to converge in the limit in the
mean sense to the distribution that we
have and so what we can do is we can use
the polynomial chaos representation to
represent any arbitrary probability
distribution using only gaussians or
using only uniform or and the variables
as long as that target distribution has
a finite second moment finite variance
just quick question can anyone tell me
of a distribution that doesn't have
finite second moment does anyone know if
one kosha distribution it's a canonical
one in simpler terms we can represent
random variables of arbitrary
distributions by choosing by writing a
polynomial KS expansion and we get to
choose which distribution we write it
around
which is a super-powerful
concept this is like you doing a Taylor
expansion for a really nasty function we
just write it in terms of a polynomial
and we truncate it and it's very simple
all right so basically let me make this
a little bit smaller so it renders
better so there's a natural relationship
between orthogonal polynomials and
probability distributions and this is
the orthogonality condition for the
hermite polynomials orthogonality just
like in a vector space is written in
terms of an inner product we call a dot
product when working in in finite
dimensional vector spaces but what this
is is the inner product is written in
terms of literally the product of two
functions times a weighting function we
integrate that over the domain and then
we get something that comes out at the
end and in this case we're writing it in
terms of the the Kronecker Delta which
means that if our two functions H I and
H J if I is not equal to J then the
orthogonality says that that inner
product is equal to 0 but if you notice
the terms on the red here let me scroll
over that looks really familiar right
that term looks super familiar and in
fact what that is is that's just our
standard normal probability density
function so the hermite polynomials in
this case they're orthogonal T condition
is written in terms of this standard
normal distribution so we can use this
to represent basically any finite
variance random variable in this I'm
going to change nominal h éeer here I'm
going to call it K writing it in terms
of series of harmik polynomials about a
Gaussian so if I have some random
distribution that represents my customer
data I want to represent it in terms of
polynomial a series of polynomial
hermite polynomials and then I want to
compute these deterministic coefficients
so this is just like doing a Fourier
transform where we have we know what the
form of the function is we just need to
get the coefficients that's what the
exercise is all about so we can do this
using a technique known as the gallery
in projection so we take that series and
what we're going to do is we're going to
take the inner product of that series
and first we're going to do it we're
going to take the inner product with the
first orthogonal polynomial and on the
second orthogonal polynomial and we're
going to do that all the way up to
infinity or we're actually going to
truncate it at at P and so what you get
is an expression that very
deterministically tells you what these
coefficients are these K is and so you
get this integral that comes out it's
the one over the orthogonality condition
times this integral in terms of hermite
polynomial the problem is that this
integral is actually kind of
mathematically meaningless because we
don't know what K is if we could write K
in a closed form we wouldn't be doing
this exercise at all and so what we're
going to do is we're going to do
something called an inverse sample
transform we're going to move Zita and K
so Zetas are Gaussian random variable
and K is our nasty random variable we're
going to move them to the same uniformly
distributed random variable and we can
do that because they're fully dependent
so kind of breezing through this here to
get to the code we transform both of
these onto a standard uniform
distribution and we put that into the
integral and now we have this form on
the right which is very easy to compute
this is something that we can write code
for very easily it's just the inverse
CDF of our target distribution which we
can compute we can approximate
numerically if we want times the
polynomial now evaluated over the
inverse CDF of a Gaussian so that allows
us to compute these coefficients we're
going to do this P times get all of
these coefficients and then that's all
that's all we need to do in order to
represent our random variable in these
forms so there's a few ways that we can
compute this orthogonality condition it
has a closed form basically just a
factorial there's a few different ways
to handle this in practice either you
can just compute the factorial which I
didn't do because I've written a
factorial function about a million times
in my life and I was bored
we can - in practice normally what we do
is we actually rescale Zeta so that the
orthogonality condition comes out to be
just the Kronecker Delta or we can just
compute the integral using a Gauss
Carmike quadrature which is basically
prepackaged
to fit the problem that we already have
so now we're pulling in this very
standard integration technique and it's
all ritz hand-tailored for the problem
that we have which is very very cool so
we're going to do that okay and that's
all the math setup so I'll take a break
there and if anyone wants me to go back
to anything let me know right now that
was a huge amount of like here's like
two semesters worth of math dumped on in
your lab okay so just to recap what
we're going to do is we want to
represent a random variable K in terms
of a Gaussian so I'm going to choose a
uniform distribution I'm going to
represent it in terms of a Gaussian by
computing these ki coefficients and then
reassembling it at the end in order to
do that I'm going to run some Python
code we don't need a lot to make this
happen
in fact half the code up here is just to
make the plots work so we're going to
use numpy we're going to there's a the
hermite polynomials are already bit
built into numpy that's really
convenient for us psy high stats I'm
importing norm from there because I just
didn't feel like writing the inverse CDF
function when I could just import it
there's a really interesting
representation rational function
representation of the inverse normal
distribution if you're ever curious I
don't know where they'd like it was
computed back in like the 30s and it has
these just arbitrary numbers at some
poor grad student had to compute someday
yes I can so we'll run that
and then so what I'm going to do here is
a couple of utility functions we had to
define a method that really just gives
me the coefficients for the ice hermite
polynomial it all this is is this is
just a vector of zeros with the nth term
being a 1 so that represents like h2 h3
h4 whatever and then a utility method
for the inner product I'm just going to
use it to smush together two hermite
polynomials use the built-in library to
multiply them together and so I don't
have to do all of that work and then
I'll return a function for that so
that's pretty basic and then I'm going
to set up a basic trapezoid integration
method this is your standard method from
numerical analysis there's nothing fancy
about it here it's actually probably
pretty pretty horrid so we'll just skip
over that so what I'm doing in this
slide is I'm going to build a couple of
inverse distribution functions and I
want it I want to parameterize them in
this case I only really parameter as one
of them the uniform distribution but
these are really nice easy things to
closed-form things to right except for
the normal which I use sci fi for and so
I'm going to use these two to generate
the coefficients and that's what I'm
going to do in this kind of nasty block
of code so I'll walk through this really
quickly
so we're going to take in a degree and
order truncation order P and we're going
to take in our target distributions
inverse CDF H so we're going to once we
do that we're going to pre allocate the
K is the reason I'm pre allocating here
is because I want my code to match the
math I don't want it to be idiomatic
Python because if you want to go through
and look and say wait how did they do
this I want the code to match the math
that I'm presenting and not like some
awesome list comprehension that takes
you 20 minutes to to decompose so I'll
pre allocate the k IRA I'll set up the
the gauss hermite quadrature
that's also a built-in method in the
numpy module and then so what I'm going
to go through is for each term I'm going
to compute the inner product which is
can be done by just computing the the
value of the inner product multiplied
together here at each node times each
weight that's your basic our might
quadrature we take the sum and then for
the the integrand I'm going to set it up
so that's where we have H of U times the
hermite polynomial of the inverse cdf of
a gaussian and that's all that's all
we've got and so now the ki is computed
simply by performing this integration
this trapezoid whoops this I'm using the
trapezoid integration method here to
compute that integral and now you see
this is the way I've written it is we
take the integrand as a function our
bounds are upper and lower bounds and
then the number of points in our
partition we want to compute the
integral over 0 to 1 but with the normal
PDF or the normal inverse CDF rather if
you put in 0 and you put in one you're
going to error out because they go to
infinity so we have to pull it in a
little bit for numerical stability so
now that that's set up we can actually
just compute these coefficients but then
I'm going to also define a method that's
going to build out that random variable
from those coefficients for us so all
this is doing is it's taking the
coefficients it's multiplying them by
the polynomial and it's adding them all
up so whoops did I run that code I did
run that code ok so now we'll generate
some Gaussian random variables will
generate I don't know say 5,000 of them
and then we'll go ahead and we'll build
out this distribution and this takes
just a second so that's pretty good so
what we're doing here is we're building
a uniform distribution from gaussians
with a 13th order expansion but if we
change the order of this we can see what
happens like if we take it
from to that's just our Gaussian
distribution and as we get the order as
we increase that order we get more and
more like a uniform distribution so it's
really sufficient to truncate these
expansions add a pretty small number of
terms and this is pretty good
you wouldn't like build a random number
generator around this it's not that good
but if you had a really nasty
distribution that you really can't
describe with with good clothes for
mathematics this is a really quick and
handy way to do it and just to go over
what those kis are this is what's really
interesting once you compute those K is
what we'll do is we'll take a look at
the first one this is a zeroth order
coefficient this is the mean of the
standard uniform distribution your
zeroth order coefficient is always going
to represent your mean and that's going
to become a powerful concept in the
moment but the other interesting thing
is that the second coefficient K sub one
is always going to represent your
standard deviation so the standard
deviation of a standard uniform
distribution is if you recall the
formula it's going to be basically
sending in forms the square root of 1/12
so it's very close so that second
coefficient represents your standard
deviation first coefficient represents
your mean so now we have a very good way
of using this to represent the
statistics of a process without having
to do a bunch of simulation and that's
what I'm going to do next so just to
show you that this works for other
distributions as well we'll use an
exponential distribution see what
happens that's pretty cool we can build
that out like that and if we change the
order we'll see the same type of
behavior the lower the order we get the
more it looks like a normal Gaussian
distribution and the higher we go the
better it looks so this is exactly the
behavior we want we want this
convergence behavior as we increase P
so the question is do we need to use
Gaussian random variables in this in
this process and the answer is no
there's a scheme called the Wiener ascii
scheme and you can actually use there's
a whole family of orthogonal polynomial
distributions that you can use to do
this so for your problem the uniform
distribution is is better we can use
that if for your problem you have a
discrete distribution you can also use
it around discrete random variables and
what's really interesting is that all of
these whoops
all of these orthogonal polynomial
families are related in terms of what's
over here on the left here the confluent
hypergeometric functions so it's like
this whole family and basically you can
bootstrap starting from the hermite
polynomials you can bootstrap up to
represent any distribution you want if
you know how the those functions work so
I'm actually just going to skip this
slide that's about doing it for discrete
distributions but in the interest of
time I'll go over that so let's give a
practical example suppose we want to
solve a differential equation like this
and suppose it's parameterize by K and K
is a random random process say this
represents the the attention rate on our
website right we we know that the amount
of time somebody spends on the website
falls off like this and we've built a
model for that but it's rent it's that K
is a random parameter so we could solve
this differential equation for a
specific K that's pretty easy we'll just
build out our standard runge-kutta
fourth-order method and if we solve it
it looks something like this and I guess
does one scroll on me
that's all right so suppose that we want
K to be a random parameter and you can't
read it because the displays have messed
with the windows here but it's going to
have a support s and it's going to have
a distribution function f of K and the
mean of that random parameter is going
to be K bar so we might think okay is
this the mean of our our solution do we
just solve the differential equation and
throw the mean of the random parameter
in there and say this is the mean of our
output response we do this a lot in data
science we say okay well we've got this
ugly distribution what's the average
customer look like okay now I'm going to
use the average customer my model and
say that that is because we're using the
average customer I throw it into the
model that's going to be my average
output right turns out that's not
actually the case and it the stochastic
mean if that's what you really want
looks more like this which is really
hard to compute especially if you have a
really nasty distribution so we don't
want to do this this is not a productive
thing to do and so we're going to use a
few different techniques one of them
could be direct Monte Carlo simulation
which I'm going to do here so we're
going to generate a thousand samples of
this solution to this ordinary
differential equation and it's going to
run and run and run that's
a fourth order runge-kutta integrator
standard methods for solving OD e it
takes about a minute the suspense is
purposeful
so we can see already that this is like
not really what we want to do this is
not the best use of data scientist time
running direct Monte Carlo simulations
because that's at only a thousand
samples which is not enough for
statistical accuracy of a the most
simple ordinary differential equation
you can get and like yeah my Python code
is really not the most optimized for
this but twenty percent of that time was
still a lot of time wasted right so if
we take a look at and seem to have lost
my scrolling capability there we go
it's back so this is our mean the mean
of our solution in the blue and then we
have our upper and lower 95% confidence
intervals and now we can say aha now I
can simulate my model for my customer
attention on my page but that took a
really long time and just for comparison
this is oops this is the stochastic mean
versus a deterministic mean so if you
actually throw in the average of that of
your random distribution and expect it
to be the average of your output that's
the red line which does not actually
match the mean of the Monte Carlo Monte
Carlo simulation so we actually don't
want to do that so we can use polynomial
chaos to make this easier easier being a
relative term considering edges through
entire book of functional analysis at
you but we've already done this work for
K right we've already built out K so now
we want to do it for for our
differential equation Y so what we're
going to do is we're going to gather
these terms we're going to just this is
called an intrusive polynomial chaos
representation we're going to take the
polynomial chaos representation throw it
into a differential equation naively and
then we're going to do the same Gallican
projection as we did before we're going
to gather the terms now we have this
really nasty looking thing which is
actually not that complicated to compute
so that triple product can be easily
computed with the gauss hermite
quadrature that what's over being
overwritten there's that this term here
the the three fees in a row and that's
just another product so we can use our
Gaussian quadrature to compute that in
very few computations we only need maybe
fifty computations in order to compute
that integral so that's super easy and
then with the inner product we can we've
already computed those so that's easy
all we need to do is generate them and
so what we get as a result of this is
going to be a system of differential
equations it's going to be a linear P by
P matrix so we're going to instead of
solving a thousand differential
equations of first order to generate our
Monte Carlo analysis we're going to
solve one differential equation of piece
order which is a huge improvement in
speed basically what we're saying is we
can generate as many samples as we want
using only p solutions to a system
versus a thousand ten thousand a million
so we'll set up that triple product as a
nice little utility method here and then
here's the meat and potatoes of it so
we're going to do represent this system
we're going to do a fifth order
expansion we're going to solve that
differential equation that I displayed
earlier for a uniform random K and we're
going to compute the statistical moments
of that distribution and compare it to
that Monte Carlo simulation that took
you know a couple minutes to run and
that's it
our solution is already done so to prove
that I'm going to plot these are the
this is the mean of the Monte Carlo
simulation in blue the dashed line is
the polynomial chaos representation the
green line is the three standard
deviations from the mean red line is
three standard deviations under the main
dashed line is is the polynomial chaos
and so what we see is that in a fraction
of the time we got pretty good results
with a pretty low order approximation of
what we're actually trying to do that's
like a orders of magnitude reduction in
computational complexity to get the
statistics that you really care about
and so just to wrap it up all up I'm
going this is the ugly line of code
don't read this I'm embarrassed by this
it's going to take just a moment to run
I'm actually going to generate the Monte
Carlo samples for the polynomial chaos
representation just to show you what
they look like compared to the direct
Monte Carlo simulation and it's not
exactly perfect
it's actually really imperfect because
polynomials are really nasty to work
with and we're not guaranteed
convergence to the entire solution space
we're only guaranteed convergence and
the limit in the main sense so this
takes a minute but it's not as fast
because I truncated it at 500 samples
okay so that's done so if we plot this
out these are our confidence intervals
let's see if I can can't scroll this
here I don't know what it is that has
made me unable to scroll yeah there we
go
so what we see is like the polynomial
chaos expansion goes like really high
and then also really low into values
that doesn't make sense it doesn't make
any sense for the solution of an
exponential decay to go under zero that
is nonsensical
so we don't actually use those that
sampling to get our statistics but if
you look at the mean of that Monte Carlo
simulation the mean is very close to the
direct Monte Carlo simulation main and
again this is only with a fifth order
polynomial KS expansion so with very few
lines of actual meaningful code and this
is all of the meaningful code that that
exists in this this modeling approach
basically with this code here and the
associated code to compute the ki
coefficients we've taken the burden of
trying to understand how our really
nasty distribution affects our random
process and brought it down to a very
basic very fast computation I'll even
run it again and it's done and so we can
do that for any any distribution we want
that has finite variance that's all that
I have I hope that was a decent
introduction I will actually take a
couple questions since I think I have a
bit of time so if anyone has any
questions or would like a clarification
on any of this I see some blank blank
faces oh you do a question now I'll do
I'll do a couple questions yeah thank
you those interesting I just for P are
there any results which tell us what P
you should use or at least bounds or
whatever which will give us some
interesting intuitions for for the
different distributions and so on um so
the intuition that I used was before we
start throwing this solution at our
process I throw it at generating the
random parameter itself and we'll go
back to where I do that so there's not
like a general rule for choosing P but
what I do is I just start increasing it
until this thing looks like
thing that I have and this is a very
low-cost computation this this takes a
matter of seconds to run yeah great talk
thank you
so so you said the first first
coefficient is like the demean yeah
second one is like the standard
deviation is there any such
interpretation for like all the other
coefficients like quit or whatever yes
they represent the higher higher moments
of the distribution with respect to the
distribution that using to model it so
if you used say a Gaussian distribution
to model another Gaussian distribution
like a standard normal to model a
Gaussian with some different variants
what you would get is mean variance and
then the rest would be zero because you
don't have like a skew or kurtosis when
in in that sense
already so thanks a lot um I think I
have a question on the the inverse
sample transform that you do so you said
that they the two variables K and theta
are fully dependent yes
and therefore you can do that how does
it work again I think I'm lost er okay
right so let me get back to that yeah so
this is the magic this is the the
magical slide so recall that a
cumulative distribution function is the
range of it is always between 0 and 1
and what we're going to say is that if
we compute the cumulative distribution
function of a random variable we can
treat that as a distribution over the
support 0 to 1 and when we're supporting
something over 0 to 1 the most natural
and simplest distribution we have is the
uniform distribution we could choose
another one that's supported on 0 1 but
the uniform distribution works very well
so we're going to say that the CDF the
cumulative distribution function of our
Gaussian which maps to 0 to 1 we're
going to call that U and the cumulative
distribution function of our parameter K
we're going to also say that that's
equal to U and we can do that because
these were declaring that these random
variables are fully dependent so we can
say that we're going to map them to the
same thing and then when we once we've
mapped them to the same thing then we
just take the inverse CDF of each and
we'll give those here I just defined
them as H and L and now what we have is
K written in terms of U and we have Zeta
written in terms of U and the reason
that we want to do that is because this
integral on the right hand side K and
Zeta are not written in terms of each
other right yet we need to get them
written in terms of
same thing in order to compute this
integral in a meaningful way
so we're basically doing a change of
variables on two different variables and
putting them into the same space
recognizing that they are fully
dependent do one more one last question
and I was wondering whether you in your
example you you had this exponential
decay where the decay get some k's as a
random variable but it was constant in
time kind of right so in would vector
does is just the whole approach work
when your random variables are so
dependent on time for example in a
classical statistic process yes it does
and it is substantially more complicated
okay and we find a question that has to
work for discrete random processes yes
it does
so I breezed through that but let me
actually go into that a little bit so
this this inner product representation
this orthogonality representation here
what we've this is a Romanian sense and
that we're taking the two functions
we're multiplying them by a weighting
function and integrating over their
independent variable right what we're
actually doing here though is if you
look at this exponential term times that
the the differential there that's
actually a measure so if we look in a
little bit Ilyas representation what
we're actually doing is we're computing
an integral over the inner product is
just in a computation over a measure and
as it turns out that this this Gaussian
term here that's just the radon nikodem
derivative of a Gaussian measure so we
can generalize this to a discrete
distribution and then use measure
theoretic concepts and just it's the
same thing but of course if we have a
discrete measure or accounting measure
then that integral just becomes a sum so
then it's a we just do the same thing
but it's simplified it becomes the sum
all right that's all I'm going to do for
now if you have any other questions feel
free to find me I'll be around for the
rest of the day thank you
[Applause]